you know if there's one place in modern
america where success
is entirely determined or has been
entirely determined by merit and skill
it's in professional sports
of course they're always going to be
controversies about this or that player
getting the starting job while this or
that supposedly better players on the
bench
but overall speaking in broad strokes
the the people playing sports at the
highest level
are there because they're simply the
best of the best
and in many cases uh these are not
people who come from
privilege and wealth you know it doesn't
or didn't matter
what your socioeconomic background was
the people playing at the highest level
were there because they were very very
talented
and had worked obsessively hard that's
one of the things i always liked about
sports you can watch sports and see
people who are extremely good at what
they do
competing against one another according
to the rules that are the same for
everyone
and may the best man or best team win
it's not a perfect system the rules
certainly aren't perfect and most
definitely aren't enforced in a perfect
way but
but still generally it works and it's
fun to watch
and all of this of course means that the
left has to try and ruin it
so over on espn sports commentator max
kellerman
yesterday expressed concern his antenna
has been raised he says
about the possibility that the top three
quarterbacks selected in tomorrow's nfl
draft
might all be white guys that's a big
problem to have too many white guys
drafted in a row kellerman thinks and
he's not alone
uh but here he is explaining well a lot
a lot of football people really like
mac jones the more they look at them um
and so like i
like you stephen i'll defer to their
wisdom but i will say this
i think what what rubs people the wrong
way maybe like you stephen a i know it's
on my radar
is that sometimes quarterbacks rise
sometimes they fall but what i've
noticed in recent years
after decades of artificial barriers but
being put in place for black
quarterbacks that vis-a-vis white
quarterbacks black quarterbacks
in the draft tend to fall pre-draft
their evaluations
and sometimes it's right like daniel
jones looks like he's going to be better
than dwayne haskins
and sometimes it's wrong like mitch
trubisky
is not as good as desean watson or
certainly not patrick mahomes right
but i say watson because he seemed to be
the guy falling and trubisky the guy
rising and mahomes maybe
didn't do either but the point is the
correlation that can be made
is that your status falls vis-a-vis
white quarterbacks and so that's why my
antenna are up when i notice
one two and three this year white guy
white guy white guy right but that may
be correct
yes well you can't blame max kellerman
he has some unfortunate deficiencies
vis-a-vis iq points and now he's worried
that there's racism against black
quarterbacks as i said he's not alone
there's a lengthy article on the website
the undefeated claiming that
there is quote covert racism in the nfl
which makes it so that
whiteness is favored reading from the
article it says
in the case of the lead up to this
week's nfl draft covert forms of racism
and the evaluation process tend to favor
whiteness
make no mistake fields uh one of the nfl
quarterback prospects will be one of the
first five quarterbacks taken in the
draft
but the fact that he started the college
season as the consensus number two
quarterback prospect before inexplicably
dropping as low as the fifth quarterback
at times in some
mock drafts behind two white players
with lesser pedigrees is an indictment
of the antiquated system
as it pertains to black quarterbacks
now this idea that the nfl is somehow
systematically systemically
racist against black people extends
beyond the playing field we've heard for
years that there's a racist conspiracy
to keep black people from being head
coaches
the league is so concerned about this
that they've adopted a plan
to reward teams with draft picks if they
develop minority coaches who go on to
become head coaches or gm's
it's only a matter of time before
similar incentives are given to teams to
draft black quarterbacks or black
players other positions
the plan is to take this last bastion of
sanity where merit and skill have
reigned supreme
and completely destroy it by forcing it
to submit to the left's rules of
identity politics
as we've learned the left cannot allow
anything to exist on its own terms and
by its own rules
now certainly if they can invent
systemic racism in professional sports
they can do it anywhere if they can find
the white privilege
phantom in modern professional sports
they can find it anywhere so consider
this
70 percent of nfl players are black
um or rather are are people of color to
use the
politically correct phrase black people
only make up
13 of the population so that 13 supplies
nearly
three-quarters of the world's
millionaire professional football
players
and yet somehow the league is still
racist against that same group
and it gets better focusing specifically
on quarterbacks
the position where white people are
supposedly favored
four of the top five highest paid
quarterbacks in the league
are black four of the top five
and soon it'll be five of the top five
once lamar jackson gets his payday and
is past his rookie deal
so looking over to the other positions
we find that along with quarterback
the highest paid wide receiver highest
paid offensive guard highest paid
defensive tackle
highest paid linebacker highest paid
cornerback and highest paid safety
are all black and usually the highest
paid running back is black too but every
once in a while you know you get a white
guy like christian mccaffrey who bucks
that trend but generally that's the way
that would go
and we could go further the the most
high profile flashiest and highest paid
positions
on the field are quarterback wide
receiver cornerback
and probably these days pass pass rusher
so outside linebacker and defensive end
as established the highest paid
quarterbacks are black
nearly every wide receiver in the league
is black
nearly every cornerback in the league is
black and
pass rusher is a pretty good racial mix
so systemic racism
against black people in the nfl
if this is systemic racism then what
would it need to look like in order to
not be systemic racism do we need to
simply evict every white person from the
league
should we make them all water boys
should aaron rodgers be on the sideline
collecting
sweaty towels and gatorade cups what do
the race hustlers need to see
what would make max kellerman's antenna
go back down
the irony is that is that the people
pretending to stand up for minority
athletes
and we can hardly call them minority
athletes as they are the majority in
their chosen field but
the people pretending to come to their
aid are actually only cheapening and
degrading their achievements
the more artificial pressure that's put
on teams to elevate black players and
coaches
the more that those players and coaches
are robbed of their achievements by
casting the achievement as the result of
a policy
rather than their own skill and hard
work
this is already happening with black
coaches any black man hired as a head
coach
may well have gotten the job because he
was the best man for it
or it could be because of the enormous
professional and social pressure put on
teams
with head coaching vacancies to hire a
minority candidate
it's impossible to know now affirmative
action as always
hurts the people it's trying to hurt so
at least it succeeds in that
but it also hurts the people it's trying
to help
and it does it all in an effort to solve
a problem that doesn't exist
and that's why max kellerman at espn
along with all the other race-baiters at
that network which is like all of them
and in sports media um all of them today
are canceled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated